veamos si podemos calcular el volumen de
este prisma rectangular como puedes ver
es la forma que tiene un ladrillo o una
pecera de vidrio lo interesante aquí es
que las dimensiones están dadas en
fracciones aquí tenemos el ancho si a
éste podemos llamarle el ancho que mide
tres quintos de unidad el largo que mide
uno y un sexto de unidad mientras que la
altura es de tres séptimos de unidad te
invito a que le pongas pausa al vídeo y
trates de calcular el volumen de este
prisma antes de que lo hagamos juntos
bien hay dos maneras de ver esto una de
ellas es estamos tratando de encontrar
unidades cúbicas de esta figura y para
calcular cuántas unidades cúbicas
podrían caber aquí hay que tomar en
cuenta el área de la base el área de la
base se va a poner aquí con esta vez y
multiplicarla por lo que sería la altura
esta que estoy marcando aquí que es la
altura que usualmente se designa por h
esta de aquí déjame dejarlo claro que es
el
de la base y el área de la base como la
voy a calcular bueno el área de la base
la puedo calcular como el largo por el
ancho el área de la base va a ser el
largo que es esto que tenemos aquí el
largo x
el ancho que sería esta dimensión que
tenemos aquí largo por ancho largo por
ancho es el área de la base esta que
tenemos aquí vamos a marcarla y esa área
de la base vamos a multiplicar la por la
altura la otra manera de ver esto es que
vas a multiplicar largo por ancho por
alto vas a multiplicar las tres
dimensiones de este prisma para
encontrar el volumen para encontrar las
unidades cúbicas contenidas dentro del
prisma vamos a calcularlo el volumen es
igual al largo que es esta dimensión un
entero un sexto pero como vamos a
multiplicar varias fracciones es mejor
que pongamos este número mixto como una
fracción impropia así es que un entero
un sexto lo vamos a poner en sextos un
entero equivale a seis sextos un entero
un sexto son siete sextos así es que el
volumen es siete sextos que es el largo
que multiplica al ancho que es tres
quintos que multiplica a tres quintos y
que multiplica a la altura
3 séptimos que multiplica a 3 séptimos y
vamos a este producto ya sabemos que
cuando tenemos producto de fracciones
vamos a multiplicar los numeradores que
son 7 por 3
3 dividido entre el producto de los
denominadores que es 6
x
7 ahora vamos a hacer estos productos
pero para obtener una fracción que esté
simplificada que no esté tan grande
notamos que tenemos 7 en el numerador y
7 en el denominador así es que vamos a
dividir entre 7 numerador y denominador
así es que dividimos el numerador y el
denominador entre 7 así es que esto se
hace 1 y esto también se hace 1 también
notamos que podemos dividir el
denominador y el numerador entre 3
aquí tenemos 3 que entre 3 y 6 entre 3
que podríamos dividir así es que vamos a
hacerlo dividimos entre 3 el numerador y
entre 3 el denominador y que nos da 3
entre 3 nos da 1 y 6 entre 3 nos resulta
en 2 esto es igual a 2 que nos queda
entonces esto es igual a el numerador
nos queda nada más este 3 que tenemos en
verde es 3 el numerador y el denominador
es 2 por 5 esto que tenemos aquí déjame
marcarlo 2 por 5 que es igual a 10 el
volumen del prisma es entonces 3
decimos de unidades cúbicas o puedes
pensar que dentro de esta pecera o ese
ladrillo o lo que fuera caben tres
décimos de unidades cúbicas